all right you are
Johan uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally okay so originally
uh born in Germany and I lived there
till I was 14. and then I came to the
states
and Arizona was really my home in
America oh really
and tell me about your family growing up
I'm sorry tell me about your family
growing up
um well my dad wasn't there for 12 years
he's a military guy
my parents got divorced when I was
around two
he came back to the States
uh
he was actually exited from the military
because of mental illness
and my mother happens to be mentally ill
too
so for the 12 years he wasn't there I
grew up especially in Germany alcohol is
a big culture
it didn't even occur to me that my
mother was self-medicating
and by the time I was 12 years old I was
already drinking too
so it was pretty crazy I didn't know
anybody that didn't drink
and then he came back and turns out he
was a drinker too and that's eventually
I think I was telling a little bit ago
eventually what did it killed him in a
way
because he was only 68 when he died
and he should still be around
so he hasn't even been dead that long
yet uh let's say it's 23. so he's been
dead for five years
and you've had jobs
uh I have my own business uh my son now
runs it out of Arizona he's still done
some of the conference circuit stuff and
whatever
and at one point I did run the business
out here but pretty much got out of it
and 911 didn't help with that because
nobody was traveling so suddenly
that was pretty much out of illness
which is why I got into the audience
stuff out here and not so much the
technology part
and alcohol's been a constant in your
life uh I don't remember really since 12
years old I don't remember Tom I don't
drink
it's pretty much a daily habit
not working doesn't help because I have
nothing else to do so I just sit there
and drink
I'm on Social Security Now
because I have health issues and
everything else how was he 46 46.
and tell me tell me how alcohol is
affected your life well the first time I
was homeless I lived in the tent for two
and a half years and that was because I
was making really bad decisions when I
was drinking
and it cost me to lose my place to live
and everything else
it's caused me to lose relationships my
own brother and sister don't even talk
to me
although they have issues on their own
my brother has a drug habit
and my sister says she's not a drinker
like I am but uh
for some reason there's always a party
at our house
somebody's birthday something there's
something that there's always an excuse
oh we're going bowling next thing you
know attend men's tulips later or
whatever so you're freaking drinking now
so so you you mentioned there was mental
illness on your parents side yeah do you
think mental illness is really what's
behind all of this it has a big effect I
actually do see a psychologist a
psychiatrist and I've been diagnosed as
bipolar
and some of my drinking was originally I
think part of the self-medicating as
well on 10 hour radialized that I was
becoming like my parents they're both
schizophrenic
but they were functioning
so it took a long time for me to realize
what was really going on so I do take
medication but I still drink
some days it's more some days it's less
uh this morning the first thing I did is
I opened my bodily agar because I woke
up shaking
you know
am I proud of this no but it's part of
my life
but most people don't even realize it I
mean just look at me nobody even seems
to think I'm homeless
you know I make sure I look clean and
all that stuff yeah you never know and I
have a service dog that I take care of
which gives me at least something to do
so although I don't always take him with
me when I knew where you're coming down
here I definitely didn't want to bring
them and with if alcohol wasn't in the
picture where do you think your life
would be
um
that's a good question
and try actually not to think about that
I'd probably still be running my own
business
and I'd probably be healthier
I'd be traveling a lot more
because I didn't used to love that when
I had my own business
the world isn't as bad as people think
there's a lot of good people out there
from what I have seen
and there's that quote I tell people all
the time it's not the full quote but uh
Mark Twain
a travel has fatal the bigotry Prejudice
and narrow-mindedness
it's not the full quote that goes
further than that but that's what I
usually tell people
yeah because I've met so many wonderful
people
yeah my life would be doing that I would
still be traveling I would still be
running my own business instead of
having to have my son
take care of it
um and that's the other part I was
having a daughter
and
they loved me dearly but there's not
much of a relationship there either most
of the time
just because they didn't
thank God didn't end up with the
problems I had and my parents had
they're okay
and they live well what most people
would consider a normal life
you know Suburban normal house married
all that stuff
what are some of the lowest
points of your life well being in a tent
for two and a half years I was so busy
drinking I didn't even realize that the
time was passing
and then one day I woke up and I said oh
my god I've been here for two and a half
years I got to do something
and that's when I actually met my
current spouse
and he knew what was going on
and it just so happened that his uh ex
who he was still living with
I was they found a brain tumor
and they needed a caregiver
and so my spouse suggested me and I
moved in with them and he was paying me
under the table because my social
security check was going to alcohol
still does
pretty much
um
I mean when I have when I do have to pay
rent and everything else I take care of
that but whatever is left so between my
bills and the dog whatever has left us
I'll call it cigarettes and then I do
whatever I can in between to make money
here or there you know market research
things and
who knows what have you have you tried
to quit
drinking no not really
smoking yes
I've actually quit smoking for like
three months a little longer than that
but then out of habit because I've been
smoking for so long
you one day I was buying a 12 pack of
beer and without even thinking about a
pack of cigarettes
and I actually had a lighter in my
pocket but I I don't I must have picked
it up out of habits sitting in the house
without even thinking and I walked
outside the gas station and little sir
and I said to myself oh
took me until that moment to realize you
haven't smoked in three months what are
you doing
but when you've been doing this for 30
plus years
you know but what do you think keeps you
from
putting you know putting down the bottle
and stopping
a lot of it is I think just because I
have nothing really productive to do in
life at this point
and just a habit and it it does help I'm
being by Paul Miller romantic
alcohol really kind of affects me in a
different way
some people it's a real Downer or
whatever but I lived up people think I'm
a crystal meth addict and I'm not
because I can be awake for two three
days straight and drink
especially because I don't down and down
and I will stop and eat in between and
things like that
you know I maybe even have water or
something but then I go right back to my
beer or Jagermeister or whatever the
heck I picked up that day
because I'm not even picky about that
but I would whatever I have the money
for at that point in time
what is the motivation you think do you
want to escape something from your past
well there was you know besides the fact
I'd have started out I think as a
self-medicating
um
from the age of five till about nine I
was molester
and uh I actually had puberty pretty
early so from nine to because this kept
going until I was 14 technically
but I only say I was molested from five
to nine because I from that point in
life
up until age nine he was still able to
say don't say anything because No One's
Gonna believe you by age nine I was
going to him and saying don't say
anything because no one's going to
believe you
I actually started using a him because I
had hit puberty
and you so I think part of it well yeah
when I first came out as gay
I wasn't even sure if I was doing it
because I thought I was going to be gay
anyway in my life
or
because I was molested and because I
wasn't about to do something that
happened to me
besides I don't find little boys attract
usually whoever I date is older than me
my husband right now I'm 46 my husband
he's 62.
and we've been together for like eight
years and legally married will be
legally married for four years in June
June 5th
so
and it does help when he's around but
he's not even staying where I'm staying
right now
because he doesn't drink he doesn't
smoke oh the man has a half a can of
Michelob Ultra round he's drunk
it's really funny
meanwhile I was sitting there drinking
211 after 2 11 after 2 11 and people
look at me like haven't you had six or
eight of those already I'm like yeah I'm
going to the store to get a couple more
and they wonder how but I've been doing
it for so long
you know
your body's used to it yeah and again I
don't you know overdo it all like I'm
not doubting them
it'd probably take me two hours to drink
the first beer and then after that they
maybe go a little bit faster but in
between again I stop and eat I might
have a drink I have to go walk my dog
also because I am responsible enough I
want to make sure I'm aware of my
surroundings especially living in a
homeless area
you know
and I wouldn't want my dog to get hurt
because I was too stupid to pay
attention and I was too drunk so I do
have that in me that's why you know
people refer to that as like functioning
alcoholic and whatever
I can get important things done a matter
of fact for the last year now when I've
been at the tiny home for a year and a
half
but I've had a Section 8 voucher and
I've finally found the place by June 1st
I should be moving into an apartment
so
uh actually tomorrow well there's still
the will the stability of being housed
it will make a difference I do know that
because before because my husband's
homeless right now too he's just staying
in a different place we only became
homeless this time not even because of
the my alcohol or whatever
he lost his job because of covet
not because he was sick but because his
jobs were was he was laid off
they were just cutting back and between
his income and my income we're able to
afford a nice one bedroom apartment
but suddenly on my Social Security alone
no this is LA
here I can't afford the air I believe
that's pretty much it that's how sad it
is
I don't know how some people's alive at
all
so that's how we ended up homeless this
time but yeah disability of a home will
make a difference because I do know when
we live together and had an apartment
instead of drinking 211 and Crown Royal
and Bacardi and who knows what all day
every day
uh I would have Coors Light
which is not nearly as strong
and I'll buy a 12 pack and it'll last me
for two three days
versus now where I buy a 12 pack I have
to go buy more within the same net
so the stresses of being homeless and
not having anything to do
with my husband again it makes a
difference because
he does work now
and I'm like to to stay out at home
partner so I do the laundry the cooking
the cleaning you know I do the shopping
I usually manage all our bills I take
care of our insurance stuff all that
stuff
so that gives me things to do but for
the last year and a half now
I've been sitting in a tiny hole
with nothing to do other than take care
of my dog
and drink and drink
so I sit there and drink and alcohol is
not even allowed in but some of the
security knows me so well they don't
even bother looking in my bag anymore
because I don't generally bother anybody
I go in and I sit there and watch TV
but I do stuff on my phone you know
watching YouTube stuff mostly all the
time oddly enough which is funny that I
never heard of you before
so actually I would like to know about
what your channel is so I can look that
up yeah I'll tell you but um
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have known
differently
to be honest and it may sound wrong to
people but I would have never come to
America
but I didn't have much choice at the
time when we did come after my dad came
back to Germany
12 years later and my mother married him
a second time
I was 14. I could have actually stayed
in Germany
uh I have a lot of family there actually
my own father didn't like his American
family I don't talk to anyone here I
know I have a lot of them
don't like any of them my father didn't
like them but I have a lot of family and
friends in Germany I'm still in touch
with and thank God for the internet
because I use Facebook Messenger I can
call them for free and actually see them
so I'm in touch with them all the time
there's also a good chance I might be in
the closet
I may still you know meet up with men
here and there every now and then but
I'd probably be married with instantly
just two kids I'd probably have four
and I would have probably continued
going to school because at one point in
my life I wanted to be a veteran a
veterinarian
because I do love animals a lot
and I actually still talked to my
girlfriend from Germany she lives in
Austria now
but she always says you know I made some
bad decisions so did you
if one day you end up old and alone and
I'm all alone just come home
so which is comforting anyway yeah it is
we've known each other since uh sixth
grade
that's a damn long time yeah
there's people in my life I've known for
40 years
and then again there's other people that
I've known for that long but we don't
really have a relationship anymore
because the drinking can get in the way
of things it does
you know I'm generally what they say is
a nice drug I'm the guy who says I love
you you know unless you piss me off
because that can trigger my bipolar mood
swings and whatever and then um the next
one I know you're ready to go get an
iPhone I'll kill you kind of stuff
and I've scared some friends over time
because they've pissed me off when I
start yelling and screaming and breaking
stuff and
so they'd rather not be around and I get
it because when I'm sober I see what I
know what I did
no one really ever truly blacks out I
think
it might take us a minute and we might
need to get some details from people
that were around
but somewhere along the way by the next
day when we're sober we start to put the
pieces together and we go oh
only to go have another drink
and do it all over again
so yeah it's that state in Germany I'd
have a completely different life
it's just the honest truth never mind
the fact that even though I'm a
half-american I've never once
felt at home in this country I just
don't
we're just sad
what's your biggest fear now I've lived
here longer I've been in America longer
than I've ever lived in Germany I was 14
when I left Germany so I've been here
for what 32 years
and I still don't feel at home
I've met many beautiful people I've seen
like 26 States
but it's not home
and I think in a large part is
difference in culture
and
by the time you're 14 you have a pretty
good idea of who you are at least where
I came from
I had a plan for my life and then it
suddenly got thrown apart because my dad
came back
and my mother said to me what do you
think should we go to America
and I said if you really want to go
because I'm the first one that I met on
my mommy's voice
so
and I wasn't about to just let my mother
go to America with this man I didn't
even really know even if he is my dad
so but your biggest fear
at this point in your life in general
almost here really being alone
which I am a lot
so I'm working really hard I'm just
excuse me sorry
that's what I'm looking forward to
getting the apartment and my husband
being able to move in and getting back
to a sense enormously
the companionship yeah can help a lot
right yeah because especially with his
age there's not really any sexual
relationship at this point in the
beginning there was eight years ago
but now if he feels like it every two or
three months it's almost a surprise
but again that doesn't even bother me
because we do have that love
you know and that's important
and he he he knows how to deal with me
because he sees how I'm sitting there
and I'm drinking
and he doesn't like it of course he
doesn't like it we've had that
conversation more than once
but he also knows what triggers me to
become an angry drunk so he just stays
out of my way at that point
for example one of the big things is
don't dare talk to me while I'm watching
Jeopardy
I will lose it especially if I've been
drinking
pisses me off in the Wind
especially because I know that alcohol
pretty much can kill your brain and
whatever so I I've been watching
Jeopardy for as long as I can freaking
remember because if I'm going to start
forgetting one thing at least I'm
learning something else you know
so I actually know a little bit about a
lot of stuff and when I had my business
actually at one point that's when Alex
was still alive
um they were actually short on our
audience and I had to supply audience
for Jeopardy
yeah just like Price is Right when Drew
Carey took over
a lot of people just didn't get tickets
to The Price is Right
and I had to get an extra policy because
CBS was worried if I brought my people
in a lot if something happened
uh that they would sue CBS
uh so I had to get another policy just
before CVS would even let my people in a
lot a million dollar policy just to make
sure
if any one of my people got hurt that I
would be covered and that CBS wouldn't
have the problem
and then after about a year that Drew
Carey finally started getting enough
people we stopped working for the price
was right
but I did a lot of shows like that
emotionally what do you go through
depression or
I'm sorry emotionally what do you go
through depression
anger anxiety and that's where it does
happen you know and it is depressing
when you live like this that I think
that's part again why it's the drinking
is more out of control than it's
normally ever been in my life
because I'm just sitting there twiddling
my thumbs with nothing to do it's very
depressing
very depressing at least now I finally
have something to look forward to after
months and months and months of looking
for an apartment
because
by law they can't turn away someone with
a Section 8 voucher
but better but they do
so you have to find just the right
landlord
or and then if you
you even learn not to tell them that you
have a sexually voucher you get them to
show you the Empty Apartment first
because then you have proof so to speak
because then all they can do is they'll
find another reason why they won't take
the voucher and they can't ever
obviously ever be because of the voucher
because of Equal Housing rights and all
that stuff
and then it usually becomes a credit
issue or who knows what
suddenly the rent is too high and the
voucher doesn't cover it so after a lot
a lot of failed attempts I finally found
a place
it's in a neighborhood I really don't
want to be in
but in about a year or two from now once
my credit gets a little bit better again
too because my credit took a bigger hit
just as a living on Social Security is
hard to begin with
uh but my credit took a hit because I'm
suddenly homeless and I'm using credit
cards that I can't afford to pay and my
husband was unemployed and we're living
off of my income you know
so once my credit is better I'll be able
to move to a better neighborhood again
although it's not really that bad 78th
Street in Maine
it's not really that bad of an area it
used to be a lot worse than years ago
for a White Guy it's not not I should be
okay I don't really think that's going
to be a problem yeah
part of that they'll look at it like the
whole gentrification thing or whatever
yeah I'm a white gay guy I'm only going
to make the neighborhood better that's
the truth of it by the time I move out
of that apartment I'll probably be able
to charge twice the rent because it'll
look 10 times better than it did
when I moved in and I'm sorry it's a
lousy thing to say but stereotypes are
just for a reason but your ass I will be
decorating and painting and I'll
probably reface all the cabinets and all
that and I'm not even going to charge an
afford or anything else I'll just leave
it it'll be an upgrade compared to what
they have now
Johan what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
when I drink I try to stay away from
people
because I know it will cause me problems
so pretty much and my grandmother's
advice which basically translates to as
long as you have feet you better keep
walking
so that's really
all right the best thing I know you just
don't give up no matter how sad it gets
yeah I may drink all freaking day long
but while I'm drinking all freaking day
long when you see me walking down the
street with that Subway cup or Jack in
the Box cup or whatever I ain't drinking
soda or tea
I'm still going to do what I need to do
but I'm also drinking my vodka or Rum or
whatever the hell I'm drinking at that
moment walking right down the street
walking right past you and you drive no
freaking on it most people look at me
and they don't think I'm homeless
you know
they don't see any of that
so yeah you learn to stay away from
people people will use you
manipulate you when you when you drink
too much and all that
and I'm too old for that
I do want to slow down but if I ever
really truly will
right now my goal is to just get back to
where I was before this whole
homelessness happened
and it's the second time I've been
homeless I don't ever want to be
homeless again
for the first time around it was
definitely my fault because I was making
horrible to whoms
second time covet
I don't know all right Johan thank you
so much for sharing your story no
problem at all wish you the best
actually kind of nice especially if we
can help somebody else
you know I know there's resources out
there but not everybody can deal with
that actually I'll tell you this
I went to an AAA meeting once you know
what I felt like when I left
I actually wanted to drink even more
and that's exactly what I did I went to
the nearest liquor store and bought a
drink because just sitting in that
environment was so depressing and took
so much emotion out of you
that it actually was draining and I
needed a drink
I almost felt like I had to restore
myself so the place that should have
helped me actually made me want to drink
even more
which is just sad
all right let that slide thank you very
much C'est La Vie right